Tyrese Gibson social media meltdown plus
Beyonce in the Lion King someone checked
my polls hello everyone
the Dodgers did not win the World Series
last night but Beyonce's hometown of
Houston did plus she's gonna be in the
live-action Lion King so that's exciting
we'll have more on all of that in just a
few but first Tyrese Gibson seems to be
in a lot of turmoil right now between
the Dwayne Johnson controversy his
custody battle with his ex and this
emotional plea on Facebook that has
everybody talking this is all I got
don't take my baby okay away from my
baby for too much et has learned that
Tyrese has had to monitored visits with
his daughter and one was just last night
now in a statement to ET his ex Norma's
attorney says quote his emotional
outburst yesterday was nothing more than
a means of misleading and manipulating
his friends and fans et's Kevin Frazier
was with Tyrese exclusively today as he
headed into court to battle his ex who
alleges he abused their ten-year-old
daughter claims that's how Reese denies
your daughter means everything to you
and that's the thing I've seen
if she don't wrap this up today I can't
go on vacation this nightmare is not
gonna end my baby's not home you
understand I understand
they call me crazy they say I'm having
mental meltdowns on the internet I am
because you're judging me because you
still get to go home to your dog I don't
have my baby now in his 24-hour social
media meltdown Tyrese also attacked Fast
& Furious co-star Dwayne Johnson again
for getting his own spin-off on
Instagram Tyrese posted this shot with a
threat quote if Dwayne isn't fast 9
there will be no more Roman Pearce
however a source close to the Fast &
Furious franchise tells ET drain would
not likely return to fast night anyways
so the threat is quote kind of moot
either way it looks like Tyrese has a
lot to work through and we'll have more
with him tonight on ET but switching
gears right now to something very
exciting Beyonce joins the cast of
Disney retelling of the Lion King that's
right the queen bee will rule over Pride
Rock as Nala in the live-action movie
out in 2019 if you can't tell I'm
excited Disney and be herself shared the
star-studded cast announcement yesterday
and she is in some seriously good
company as previously announced she'll
play opposite Donald Glover as Simba
which means we get Beyonce and childish
gambino on can you feel the love tonight
and I don't think I'm ready for that
jelly James Earl Jones will reprise his
role as Mufasa and rounding out the cast
is she would tell Ejiofor ask scar alfre
woodard as Surabhi as well as Billy
Eichner and Seth Rogen as Timon and
Pumbaa can we get some thumbs up if you
guys are excited for this Lion King cast
I think this is so epic and summer 2019
cannot come soon enough all right but
before we sign off I was pretty hyped
yesterday about the Dodgers going into
Game seven of the World Series we know
how that ended but it was such a good
series and I was there to bring you guys
along for all the fun we did it baby
Game seven of the World Series we are
back here at Dodger Stadium where
tonight we're gonna find out who takes
home the title the Dodgers or the Astros
I'm high
this town is pumped but someone overcome
with emotion and nerve
kenji odd because how stoked are you to
be here right now game 7 Dodgers vs.
Astrid I'm stoked nervous excited
nervous all all of those emotions yeah
yeah yeah I'm really just I really want
this for I really want this for the City
of LA I mean it sounds crazy to say but
I really do
how they're not like five to twelve
bodyguards following that guy thirty
years in the making I know you're a
hardcore Dodgers fan I mean what does it
mean to be in a lot you know I'm telling
you it's a little bit early you know
because the purported Gable my
grandfather passed in 88 and it would be
what baseball is great.i doing is taking
something that was very negative and
then making it a beautiful thing because
the year that he died he said that the
Dodgers would win the championship and
if they do it I expect a lot of tears I
mean listen the first time I came to
Dunn state and I'm a grandfather was
drinking I said hey look at this guy
drinking and watching baseball now I've
carried on the tradition in the family
you wave the flag game one right yeah
Ashna milla last night who's the biggest
fan you or them well they're most
attractive fans
I'm the guy that sits in the back and go
there your tables ready baby doesn't go
to beer I want to start with your
Dodgers look today I mean come on this
is uh you're sporting some real blue
here was the easy game dress today for
this I hear that's the same shirt you've
been wearing since Game one is that your
good luck charm I know Justin Hartley
was here at Game one a huge fan I mean
have you been rub it in his face and
texting him selfies from Game seven was
fun while it lasted and a major congrats
to the Houston Astros that was an
exciting series and with everything that
city has been through the past several
months how amazing is it that they've
taken home their first World Series
title but that's enough Sports Talk out
of me all right we'll be back tomorrow
with the entertainment stories everybody
is talking about so be sure to ring that
Bell in the meantime right thanks and
goodbye